the left has declared it will no longer
act with civility as if it ever acted
with civility in the first place or had
even the slightest idea what civility
means meanwhile the president is telling
Jimmy Fallon to act like a man
a dirty Virginia restaurant kicks out
press secretary Sarah Sanders and a
muscular national policy is paying
dividends from our southern border all
the way to Iran we will analyze the key
to civility acting like a man speaking
of Manning up a World Cup update from
daily wire to sports correspondent
Jeremy the god-king boring finally
feminism ruins The Incredibles and
everything else
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
plus we also have big news I have to
announce this this is gonna be huge if I
know the internet people are gonna like
this in a special livestream this coming
Monday July 2nd at 7 p.m. Eastern we
will be joined by special guest Jordan
Peterson to celebrate Independence Day
God King Jeremy boring will host a new
edition of daily wire backstage with me
ben shapiro
andrew Clavin to look back on our
country's birth and look ahead to its
future subscribers will even be able to
write in live questions for us to answer
on the air again that's this Monday July
2nd 7:00 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
with special guest
Jordan Peterson you can find our special
live stream on Facebook and YouTube so
don't miss it I can't wait when we bring
Jordan on I'm gonna do that thing that
that lady interviewer did to him you
know he'll say like oh yeah you know
liberty is really nice in the
Declaration of Independence and I'll say
so you hate women so you so you're
saying you hate women Jordan is that
right no no what about my expression do
you think made me think about that a and
I'll say well it's just you cuz you hate
women Jordan don't you say it
so yeah Jordan is what we're gonna do
it's gonna a lot of fun we got to bring
on daily wire to correspondent soon
before we do that we got to make a
little money honey because now we don't
only have to keep this network on the
air the daily wire we got to keep out
daily wire too so that we can keep
getting updates about the World Cup and
I want to thank a wonderful sponsor
Skillshare Skillshare is so good I hope
you're already using it if you're not
you're foolish not to Skillshare is an
online learning platform with over
20,000 classes in business design
technology and more I have to keep
checking the read on that is every time
I look they have more classes that they
keep adding they're constantly adding
new stuff you can take classes in social
media marketing illustration data
science mobile photography creative
writing you name it they've got it
whether you're trying to deepen your
professional skill set start a side
hustle or just explore a new passion
skill share is there to keep you
learning and thriving take it from me
folks I've had a lot of weird jobs in my
life working in politics and show
business I've always had a million side
hustles and I've always found I just
throw spaghetti at the wall and then one
of those pieces of spaghetti ends up
being a blank book and makes me a lot of
money and
allows me to get married to sweet little
ELISA you really it's really important
to diversify your skill set I'm not
saying that you also can learn how to
not write a book but you can at least
learn a little bit about social media
marketing I have a lot of friends who
are making a lot of money doing that on
the side that is always changing I
really like staying up to date by
looking into what Skillshare has to
offer on that definitely a check it out
so join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for my listeners not
for nobody else just my guys two months
of Skillshare for just 99 cents that's
less than a buck Skillshare is offering
the Michael Nolt show listeners two
months of unlimited access to over
20,000 classes for just 99 cents you
would be foolish not to do it I hope
you're doing it already seriously it
will make your life better if you know
more things and you can explore your own
hobbies and also make a little money to
sign up go to Skillshare comm / michael
mi CH AE l Skillshare dot-com / michael
mi CH AE l to start your two months now
Skillshare dot-com what did I say /
Michael so today we're there's this big
debate going on right now between
civility some people are saying we're
not going to be civil any more week what
is civility Republicans you're not civil
Democrats you're not civil and you're
not nice and your civility and nice
things are totally different and one
aspect that they're missing about
civility is manliness manliness and what
better way to start off a conversation
about manliness then to get an update on
the World Cup you know the manliest game
of all so we turn out of our sister
network daily wire to and chief soccer
sports correspondent Jeremy the god-king
boring Jeremy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bada-boom
thank you Michael mich AAL it's good to
be with you after what sports
commentators all over the world are
calling the most intense weekend of
sweaty athletic men not scoring since
Thermopylae yes I am talking about the
FEMA World Cup for our American viewers
that's the once every four years global
sporting event that doesn't involve
curling or figure skating or bombing
Iraq in the most shocking match of the
weekend or away with the GDP literally
lower than Bill Gates defeated recent
global superpower Russia by a staggering
three points those being the only three
points scored in the match after Tom
Arnold responded to the match by
promising to deliver never-before-seen
video of US president Donald Trump
covered in urine praising Russia on its
near win and reminding his constituents
that America isn't much better than said
soccer if you really think about it
hurgh ways coach responded to the
alleged video by dying mysteriously of
polonium poisoning in the all-important
Group F this weekend saw Mexico GDP one
point zero four trillion edged out South
Korea GDP one point four trillion to one
while Germany GDP three point four
trillion defeated Sweden five hundred
and eleven billion dollars by the same
score you know what that means for Group
F right Michael of what does that mean
Jeremy yeah why would anyone know the
answer to that well I was hoping you
knew of course the most anticipated
match of the day today is between one of
the most gay friendly countries in
Europe Portugal GDP 200 billion and
nuclear wannabes and throwers of gaze
off of cranes array of GDP 393 billion a
quarter of which was a gift from John
Kerry Iran has promised that their
football program is only intended for
peaceful purposes and that the fact that
it fits neatly on the head of one of
their enormous intercontinental
ballistic missiles is strictly
coincidental and also a lie told by the
Great Satan who they hope dies but whom
they mean no personal harm as they are a
peaceful nation the beautiful sport the
beautiful sport indeed but of course
soccer isn't really Michael about who
wins and who loses it's really about
women thinking men with accents and zero
body fat
and stripy shorts are cute and everyone
else rebuking America capitalism Western
hegemony masculinity adulthood and Jesus
either seriously Jesus never watched a
single World Cup you can look it up
that's in the Bible in the Bible
evidence of this can be seen in much of
the reporting on the world cup
medium.com put out a list of 10 reasons
you should watch the World Cup reason
number 1 Team USA isn't in it take that
America reason number 3 it's a great
medicine against American arrogance
al.com and there are five reasons you
should be watching the World Cup said
it's a true World Cup you guys four
billion people cannot be wrong
fortunately for our audience at home we
here at daily wire to did an in-depth
investigation into the question of
whether or not for a billion people can
be wrong and discovered this shocking
information this is a map of all of the
nations in the world that love soccer
and this is a map of all of the nations
in the world that have landed a man on
the moon and returned him safely back to
earth that's right losers it's America
won everybody else zero a score soccer
lovers the world over should be able to
get their heads around Michael but a
boom what do you Jeremy that is some
incredible in-depth research that you
have done I did have a question about
the Iranian soccer game so do we have
any information on whether all of the
sanctions against Iran the international
sanctions have prohibited Ford and
Chrysler minivans from pulling up to the
stadium there and picking up the
children from the game you know
interestingly enough Michael soccer moms
in Iran actually are well equipped and
in other good international news soccer
moms in Saudi Arabia are now actually
legally allowed to drive to the field to
pick up those adorable six-year-olds as
they learn basic motor skills that that
is really wonderful I'm so glad that
those World Cup players will now be able
to get their juice boxes in some of
those countries where heretofore the
soccer moms couldn't drive Jeremy the
god-king boring what an incredible recap
I look forward to hearing more
are you gonna be watching more of the
games watching but upon Jeremy the
god-king boring everybody really
important update they're really really I
thought it was gonna be able to make it
through that with a straight face years
and years of conservatory training not a
chance
absolutely not really good stuff I got
to tell you the World Cup was kind of
bothering me you know because I don't it
I went to my favorite bagel place in LA
this weekend my one refuge I thought
from the kind of LAPC hippie dippie
stuff I go to buy a bagel and what do I
see
- giant TVs with the World Cup on a big
sign it says the place to watch the
World Cup your bagel place and I think
okay but watching those updates I think
I'm really starting to change my opinion
I'm getting a real kick out of this
World Cup okay so moving on from you
know the manliest sport the beautiful
game of soccer let's start talking about
manliness here because manliness is is
the question of this you know Donald
Trump saying act like a man Jimmy Kimmel
and then people saying you're not being
civil you're not what is this what it
okay it's manliness and womanliness or
misunderstood across the political
spectrum and it's playing out in our
politics you're seeing it in politics
you're seeing it on TV you're seeing it
in movies we're gonna we're gonna get to
the incredibles by the end but feminism
totally destroyed Incredibles - and it's
really sad this misunderstanding of what
of what manliness is over the weekend
we'll begin with Donald Trump and Jimmy
Jimmy Fallon and then we'll be able to
move into I think Maxine Waters and
Sarah Sanders getting kicked out of that
restaurant and why that cartoon wasn't
any good over the weekend
here's where it began Donald Trump gave
Jimmy Fallon important advice here's the
exchange do we know if Donald Trump is
part Italian he looked he looked very
Italian in that photo
that no I was actually I apparently that
was a recreation that was Marlon Brando
and was an Al Martino who played Johnny
Fontane somebody yeah really I think
they really captured the essence the era
of President Trump and Jimmy Fallon
Jimmy Fallon has been complaining for a
little while over how mean the left was
to him after he did that interview you
remember he did an interview with Donald
Trump on his show during the campaign
and he kind of rubbed his hair he said
I've got a question for you is your hair
real and he says touch the hair and he
goes rubs it oh the hair is real right
just classic a Jimmy Fallon show you
know Jimmy Fallon is the nice guy
Stephen Colbert he's the left-wing
political guy and Jimmy Kimmel he's the
everyman your average Joe but he's a
left winger too right and Jimmy Fallon's
dick is that he's the nice guy and
everybody likes him and he's not gonna
ask you about abortion he's just gonna
play games with you on his show you know
he started playing board games with his
guests and things like that Don Rickles
was asked if he'd ever been on the Jimmy
Fallon show
he said no yes to learn how to play
Jenga first you know I mean that's
that's the tenor of Jimmy Fallon show so
he has Trump on in plays with his hair
and then by the way he had Hillary
Clinton on the next week and he played
stupid games with her too and it's just
oh nice nice nice and he got eviscerated
for this by the left not the right that
was attacking him it was the left they
said you're normalizing Trump as though
the nominee of the Republican Party is
and hasn't been normalized as though the
guy that we've all known for 40 years in
the pop culture he hasn't been
normalized until Jimmy Fallon scratches
him on the scalp then all of a sudden
he's a real threat so they were so mean
to him and it kind of broke the guy that
this is gonna play an important role a
little later in the discussion between
the difference between civility and
niceness
because Jimmy Fallon man he's just a
nice guy here is Jimmy Fallon
just crying basically really upset and
complaining about what the left did to
him after he talked to Trump on the show
I'm just doing five hours a week and I'm
like working I get in at you know 10 the
morning I work till it's 7:00 at night
I'm just trying to make a funny show you
know the grind so you know and you know
me I should have been worried when we
were number one and whatever so I never
cared about that I never will I just
want to make sure we had the
best show possible yeah but it was
definitely a down time and it's tough
for morale for you know people is 300
people that work here and so people
talking that bad about in ganging up
onion really gang mentality on blow it
was insane it was a people you wouldn't
expect and your sensitive guy you go
what you cook all right we get it
I heard you right you made me feel bad
so now what are you happy you I'm
depressed do you want to push me more
what do you do I know what I mean you
let me kill myself what would make you
happy get over it you've said your only
regret about it really is that you
didn't speak to quell the issue sooner
is that right yeah I probably should
just talked and just done interviews
immediately after your like I don't dude
I don't believe in well you don't do a
lot of interviews and politicians I
don't but it's like I hope to talk to
you every night right why would I be on
a show I'd the fact you know hopefully
people do it in but I go yeah I'm sorry
I don't want to make anyone angry and
that's it there all he says pretty cool
actually sort of feel bad for the guy
because he didn't sign up for this he's
actually trying to keep his late-night
show nonpartisan but he said they all
ganged up on me
and the left loves ganging up these days
the gang they first of all they're
defending ms-13 they're defending one of
the worst gangs in the world violent
gangs then they can't you know Maxine
Waters are saying gang up on it when you
see someone gang up that that woman who
owns the restaurant the Red Hen in
Lexington Virginia said gang up on Sarah
Sanders go gang up on her you will get
to that in a minute he's seeing that oh
they're all getting ganged up on me and
that's what the left does they do gang
up but that's just the way it is
so of course president Trump responds
here in his very trumpian way he says
Jimmy Fallon is now whimpering that all
he had that he did the famous hair show
with me where he seriously messed up my
hair and that he would have now done it
differently because it is said to have
humanized me he's taking heat he called
and said monster ratings be a man Jimmy
be a man Jimmy so of course it is kind
of funny you know cuz he says he messed
up my hair be a man right now that is a
kind of funny juxtaposition but that
last advice in there be a man Jimmy is
really important it's something to
lacking in the culture right now and the
question is what is a man what is a man
because the right gets this wrong
sometimes to you it is true that the
left is all these soy boys as they are
called but the the the right sometimes
has this obsession in dark corners of
the internet with alpha males and beta
males and bah blah I know I'm gonna kill
dragon Baba right but that isn't
manliness either you find manliness in
the virtues for that's where the word
virtue comes from its from vir vir which
is which is man in Latin virtue there is
a virtue in acting like a man
Harvey Mansfield wrote that good book on
it manliness and he says that you know
manliness has a sort of brutal force to
it but it also has a refinement into
politeness so he gives the example
sometimes the it's manly to hold the
door for a woman and allow her to enter
before you go in and then sometimes it's
manly to push her out of the way and say
get out of my way I've got to stop the
bad guy right both of those things are
manly and they seem they seem different
but they they're part and parcel
manliness is not nice Jimmy Fallon is
nice
that's why Donald Trump tells him he's
got to act like a man manliness is not
nice niceness is pleasantness to be nice
as like over the oh he's such a nice
guy's Pleasant he's agreeable being
nicest being agreeable you know Alan
Blum who wrote the closing of the
American mind in the 1980s he indicted
but all of the American students that he
knew by saying that they were nice the
nicest thing the best thing you can say
about these students is that they were
nice and we meant as their shallow they
don't stand for anything they don't have
any core beliefs they're uncultured
they're uneducated they're not they're
just that they're just nice and you know
manliness is not nice it just isn't nice
to be agreeable go along to get along be
timid be a pushover that is not the same
as being manly and Donald Trump is not
nice our government right now is not
nice it isn't doing nice things that
doesn't mean it's uncivil you know
manliness right now is paying dividends
for our government and we're seeing it
every day more and more each each day we
see
this manliness right now an unknown is
respecting restoring civil government
it's restoring civility to our
government just look on foreign policy
it came out today
that the Iranian Foreign Minister Javad
Zarif is saying that ripping up the Iran
nuclear deal could topple the Iranian
regime now you've probably heard the
name of javad zarif before he is John
Kerry's boyfriend he was the guy you
know like late at night on Saturday
nights John Kerry picks up the phone
once Teresa's gone to bed
hello Javy Javy are you there Javy I'm
just oh I miss you Javy I miss you I'm
thinking of died miss you're through
yeah I just I've been thinking about you
a lot you don't call anymore Joe right I
mean it and a half exaggerating here but
he actually does still call this guy
which is a whole separate issue that the
former Secretary of State is
undercutting u.s. foreign policy here by
dealing directly with the foreign
minister of Iran when that foreign
minister is saying the current US policy
that Donald Trump is pursuing the
aggressive muscular masculine foreign
policy is possibly gonna topple our
regime and we're there's a lot of
evidence that isn't just bluff from the
foreign minister the Iranian rial the
Iranian currency has just plunged to a
record low against the US dollar there's
a major Indian energy company it just
cut its Iranian or oil imports by half
Russia's second biggest oil producer has
was going to start building projects in
Iran it is halted all development there
so there are actually real serious
warning signs here and by the way all of
the people who are these big Trump
critics I think of some of the
neoconservative types at some of the
magazines you know they're they they're
the ones pushing for regime change in
Iran but they weren't able to affect it
the Obama administration wasn't able to
affect it obviously the Bush
administration didn't pursue regime
change in Iran
it looks like Donald Trump is actually
the one who's going to do it their
protests pouring out into the streets
right now we were told oh no if you rip
up the Iranian nuclear deal you're going
to embolden the regime in Iran it's ago
they're gonna be emboldened by this was
keeping them at bay
well no that isn't what's happening a
little muscle goes a long way Donald
took out that ad in the New York Times
in 1988 I think it was at the end of the
Reagan era and he said there's nothing
about us national policy that a little
backbone can't cure we're actually
seeing this that play out and it isn't
nice but it is helpful that strong
foreign policy has gotten North Korea to
the table right gotten that crazy
dictator with nuclear weapons to come to
the table and possibly we can find to
come to some sort of nuclear arrangement
who knows we're in again we're in inning
one or two of that but it got them to
the table previous administrations were
not able to do that how about on
domestic policy that's that's the least
and nice isn't it that's the area where
Donald Trump you know is ripping babies
from their mother's arms
never mind that all the pictures that
we've been shown aren't actually
separated children
never mind that they can't point to
examples of that never mind that Barack
Obama did the same thing actually on a
much larger and worse scale never mind
any of that they're saying it's so not
nice it's mean it's inhuman Tom Arnold
was in this room yelling at me and
saying it's not human it's it's it's not
nice it's mean it's blah blah blah so we
cut to a poll right now from CBS
mainstream media about half of Americans
say that we need to send illegal
families back 48% of Americans we catch
them at the border we have to send them
back that is just this is a recent poll
that's despite the mainstream media
spending 176 minutes during six days
covering the poor little children in
this very emotional coverage mainstream
media spent six and a half minutes
covering Barack Obama when he did
exactly the same thing on a larger scale
that means that I'm no math expert that
means that the mainstream media spent 27
times more coverage on Donald Trump all
of these emotional segments nevertheless
about half of Americans they send them
back because that's what we want it is
maybe that's not nice maybe it would be
more agreeable if we just rolled over
and we're pleasant it so come into the
country anyone who wants to come in come
on in bro you want to bring drugs that's
bring it it's okay I'm not gonna stop
you cuz I'm a nice guy I'm a nice guy so
why would I stay okthat's oh you want a
traffic inhuman little babies and you
want to have little kids come over and
force them to work on farms oh that's
okay I'm not gonna stop you I'm really
agreeable oh that's what you want to
sexually assault women at the border at
a rate of 60 to 80 percent well I'm not
going to
because I'm such a nice guy no this is
not a nice policy this is a civil policy
this is a manly policy this is a law and
order policy but that's what we need
that's what we need right now and then
America agrees with that do you know
that right now half of Americans say
that we need to build the wall half of
Americans that that number would have
been unthinkable even two or three years
ago but we were now seeing when the
rubber meets the road and you get rid of
all of the sort of pleasantries and the
shallow niceness what the issue is where
the conflict really lies and Americans
want to protect their border because
we're a nation of laws
we're not a nation of men that's not
what we're supposed to be you know that
it isn't nice but President Trump has
put the mainstream media in their place
this is the distinction manliness is not
nice but it is civil civil it it means
relating to citizens it comes from the
Latin words she beliefs or key beliefs
which is you know relating to the city
relating to people who live within the
city I noticed this distinction a
left-wing reporter emailed me before
this and asked me if it's not
hypocritical they're Republicans now are
saying people need to be civil even
though in the past Newt Gingrich used to
say you know they should be Republicans
are too nice right so isn't that
hypocritical no the right is not nice
but it is civil the left is not civil
but it is nice look at the Sarah Sanders
situation so press secretary or Sarah
Sanders was kicked out of a restaurant
in Lexington Virginia called Red Hen I
mentioned the restaurant so that you
never ever go there obviously right I
mean that's they she kicked her at the
owner there was Stephanie wilkinson and
here's how the event went down because I
don't know if this parts totally been
covered so Sarah Sanders goes in with
some friends sits down at a table they
start eating the staff at this
restaurant calls up the owner Stephanie
wilkinson calls her up at home and says
the press Secretary's here what should
we do and Sarah Stephanie Wilkinson said
I'm gonna come down there and kick her
out so she goes down she's sick she
marches up to Sarah Sanders and she says
you need to leave I don't want to serve
you at my establishment so I want you to
leave and what does Sarah Sanders do she
leaves a for reaction we cut now Andrew
Garfield what do you think about that we
are
sacred and we all belong so let's just
bake a cake for everyone who wants a
cake to be baked oh that's that's sort
of surprising from the left there sit so
she should have just served Sarah
Sanders I guess right did Sarah Sanders
order cake I don't know if she ordered
cake maybe if she ordered cake or
flowers then the left would demand that
Sarah Sanders be served but maybe I
don't know maybe was roasted chicken or
something so a little bit look at that
that's though I mean it is really
incredible that on the left right now
they say we need to serve everybody how
dare you kick someone out just because
you don't want to participate in his gay
marriage ceremony
how dare that's wrong that's terrible
but if you don't if I don't like
somebody I'm not gonna serve them it is
Andrew being Sybil here no when he says
bake a cake for everybody no that's just
nice wouldn't it be nice if we just
baked cakes for everybody but it's not
civil because it actually undercuts how
citizens relate to each other in a free
republic by the way the Sarah Sanders
story doesn't end there according to
Mike Huckabee the owner of the Red Hen
nobody has really talked about this yet
followed the rest of the people across
the street so Sarah Sanders and her
husband go home the rest of their dinner
party goes across the street she follows
them across the street calls up other
people organizes a protest to yell and
scream at them from outside the other
restaurant and create this scene
definitely not civil civility is not
nice it's not glib it's not charming
it's not weak it's not timid it's not
it's not all those things that we think
it's civility means you can say hard
things nice
nice people can't say hard things civil
people can say are things it's just a
formal manner of behavior it's to say be
an adult act like a man don't be like a
little boy little children yell and
scream and they do and that's why we
don't let little children govern us the
left ones to lower the voting age at
this point I think two like seven but
wait I checked my watch for that but you
know they want to lower but when you you
have to grow up and behave as though
you're worthy of the freedom that we
have in a republic as though you're
worthy to be a citizen unfortunately we
don't have that to to just put put a
little button on it let's turn to the
emblem of the left these days crazy ol
Maxine Waters
we're gonna end it no you're not you
ain't seen nothing yet
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
we have to protect the children we have
to protect the children you can't do
anything unless you want to kill them in
the womb and then you can then do that
but didn't definitely do that don't
protect the children but but and but
then that's actually that makes you a
good person but otherwise you have to
protect the children so of course of
course
I don't even know if she understands
this I don't know if Maxine Waters
understands very much
but this is not going to turn out well
what she is proposing is mob violence
that's what she's asking for she says
when you see somebody that you disagree
with it you know like you surround them
you physically intimidate them you
scream at them you go to their place of
residence and you keep them awake at
night and you don't let them sleep and
you drive them crazy
so that bad things happen to them to
their body to their lives to their
families go and she's saying go to their
house she's saying terrorize their
families that's what that means go keep
them because by the way if you if you
have a screaming mob outside someone's
house it doesn't just mean that they
stay awake and their kids sleep soundly
at night
that's not how that works the kid it's
just terrorized people that you disagree
with this is this is civility from
Maxine Waters right and and of course
listen now she says if she goes they
don't know the Bible Reverend Maxine
father maxi bishop Maxine is telling us
about the Bible right they don't know
that but we know that God's on our side
it's on our side right the irony of this
of course it is a total misunderstanding
of what civil society is what government
is because guess what Maxine Maxine can
criticize her opponents of things she
might not understand what she's
criticizing for exactly and we can
criticize Maxine for things and then if
our solution to that is to terrorize one
another then we don't have a government
we don't have a country we don't have a
society anymore
you can't communicate if what she what
they are saying what the left is saying
Maxine Waters as their mouthpiece saying
stop communicating stop trying to get
along and live together stop trying to
deal seriously with issues but you know
in a formal manner of politeness that
allows us all to live in relative peace
and harmony she's saying forget all that
burn it all to the ground that's that's
what they want you know how does one
respond to this well the right should
still be civil the right should still be
manly you know I mean because that those
two things civility and manliness it
says everything about the person who's
doing it it doesn't say anything about
the opponent they're all kind of crazy
Maxine Waters running around and that
doesn't mean that we should get in the
muck and start terrorizing her does it
no we should we should say hard things
we should we don't have to be nice about
it but you don't want to get just you
don't want to start keeping Maxine
Waters his family up at night right
Maxine she's always been like this by
the way she loves violence during the LA
riots in the early 90s she loved that
she said oh this is what a wonderful
thing how great oh this is such a
pivotal moment and we're burning down
all of LA that's great isn't that
wonderful you know the sort of stuff
that she's advocating we're seeing it
all over the place already in Florida
the Attorney General Pam Bondi I just
came out she said three huge guys came
up were screaming at her cursing at her
one inch from her face then one guys
spit on her head that's the world that
Maxine Waters wants that's what she
wants but it's okay because Donald Trump
said a naughty word ten years ago that's
okay
Donald Trump is enforcing immigration
law immigration law that Barack Obama
also partially enforced immigration law
that was passed 10 years ago more than
that and parts of which were decided 20
years ago a keith ellison deputy
chairman of the of the democrat party is
now saying he's posing in photos with
people who say the US has stolen land
that's that's what they say they're
undercutting the fabric of the united
states itself and maybe the left is
gonna tune in to my show if you know
anybody on the Left tell them to tune in
right now because they don't because I'm
gonna give them important advice they
they don't know what civil means they
don't know what civility is you know
they don't understand these semantic
distinctions I did that Praeger video on
why words matter on how these semantic
distinctions actually matter a lot we
don't teach civics in school and so it's
no surprise that these people don't know
what it means
civics requires good faith it requires
you to be an adult
it requires virtue it requires the
virtues all of our founding fathers
talked about this they said you know
this this free republic is only fit for
a moral under religious people for an
upright people for people who educates
itself for people who works hard for
people who isn't vicious who don't have
who don't have all the vices who are you
know who possess virtues and this isn't
virtuous this isn't manly this isn't
grown-up this is an adult they're acting
like little children they're uneducated
uncultured they just scream naughty
words and they spout moral idiocy if
they're behaving like little children
but you got it people you've got if
you're gonna try to preserve the country
you got to act like a man you got to do
what real Donald Trump said to Jimmy
Fallon don't act like a little boy don't
act like a little kid you got to grow up
now speaking of children we're gonna
talk about this kids movie which which
gender politics and not being a man and
all that sort of stuff has also
destroyed before we get to it I gotta
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube I'm
sorry I got so much to talk about on the
incredibles I'm catching a little a lot
of heat and a lot of praise for my
review it's a little polarizing but I'll
explain to you why I'm completely right
if you're on Facebook and YouTube go to
daily wire.com if you're already there
thank you for being a subscriber you
help us keep the lights on you keep
coffey in my cup you what do you get you
got me at the end reclaim and show you
get the Ben Shapiro
it's ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get to ask
questions in the mailbag that's pretty
good and make sure you get your
questions in for this week none of that
matters this is what matters
fifty percent of Americans want to build
the wall mmm that's good
almost 50 percent of Americans want to
turn even hole illegal families away
when they get to the border just turn
them all away don't and just because
that's the law and we have to be a
nation of laws and let people who have
been waiting in line come in first and
we can't just give him the spirit of mmm
the majority of Americans approve of
Donald Trump's handling of the economy
including 30 percent of even Democrats I
can't take any more go to daily wire.com
get your own leftist ears tumblr you
need it you know I mean I can't I'm
gonna it's already full again I just
drank told the whole cough FA container
and it's already full back up go to
daily wire.com we'll be right back to
talk about the incredibles
feminism ruins everything
this is where we get you know I was
talking before about manliness as a kind
of the difference between being a little
child and being a grown man now I'm
gonna talk about manliness as the
opposite of feminism
there's a subtle distinction here
because feminism ruins everything it
ruins everything
it even managed to ruin the Incredibles
I have kind of a fresh face on this you
know I don't like superhero movies I
don't ever see little kids movies I just
don't go to them I only want to see like
foreign films in like Lichtenstein II
and with subtitles that I can wear a
beret to and smoke cigarettes during in
the theater I well you know I really
like those kind of more pretentious
movies but but this one a sweet little
elisa saint little elisa saint little
michael mrs. Knowles she wanted to go
see Incredibles too and so I said
alright I'll go see Incredibles too but
I've never seen Incredibles one so I
actually think I have a pretty good
perspective on this because I watched
the two movies back to back
I watched just I went straight from
Incredibles the original int and headed
to the movie theater and saw the sequel
the first movie is one of the best
movies of the last 20 years if you
haven't seen it go out and see it it is
so good and the reason why it's so good
it's it's about superheroes I guess but
it's really not about superheroes I mean
it is it is it's good in that genre but
it's so much more than that
and when movies are so much more than
those genres I tend to like them like
Logan the movie Logan is it I guess it's
a superhero movie but it's so much more
than that so I've really liked that
movie or the Dark Knight even is a
superhero movie and it and it is more
than just a superhero movie it does have
some some weight to it so I go into this
with The Incredibles and Incredibles is
about this family led by mr. incredible
he's the husband and there's a last a
girl as the wife and three kids but it's
a movie about something it's a movie
about a midlife crisis all of the other
superhero movies are just basically
popcorn movies where they all follow the
exact same formula there aren't even
spoilers that you can give to them
because we all know exactly how those
movies play out this movie isn't like
that
it's a movie about a midlife crisis it's
a movie about a guy whose glory days
were in the past when
was a superhero fighting uh you know bad
guys on his own he makes a point all the
time he says I work alone I work alone
they're telling you something it's
because he's single because he's a
bachelor because he's doesn't have kids
and a job and a car into this and he's
just got all of his adventures there and
then he trades all of that in for a wife
a stay-at-home wife and three kids and
car and a desk job in the suburbs he
trades all that in and he's kind of
miserable about it you know and he's
guys there's some drudgery to it so what
does he start doing he starts doing
things that guy's going through midlife
crisis do he starts lying to his wife he
starts staying at a little late with his
friend and just try to try to relive the
good old days and his friend is like
what are we doing man come on right
he buys a sports car and he starts going
on his clandestine rendezvous with a
beautiful young woman all without
telling his wife and when when his
selfishness when his recklessness
finally gets him into trouble what
happens it's his wife who comes and
tries to find him because she's jealous
she's nervous she you know his
selfishness is about to ruin his family
and she catches him in the arms of
another woman now of course there
because it's a kids movie they work
around this in certain ways but that's
the basic structure of even this movie
is so good even the bad guy is his name
is syndrome and it's a pun it's a pun on
sin because this it's a movie about his
own mr. Incredibles own original sin of
pride his own selfish pride the bad guy
in that movie if you haven't seen it I
don't care about spoilers because this
came out 14 years ago the bad guy was
his biggest fan as a little kid he
called himself incrediboy and you know
you've really liked him he's just he's a
manifestation of mr. Incredibles own
selfish ego it's that syndrome right as
s:y an or maybe s IM and the the you
know the syndrome character he is just a
mere mortal but he wants to be like a
superhero which is to say make himself
like a god so he creates all this
technology to try to do it right and the
only way that things come right in the
end is when mr. incredible realizes that
looking to the Past and is his old glory
days as a bachelor is looking to them as
the good old days you
that's totally backwards he says to his
kids he says and he says to his wife
you're my greatest adventure my greatest
adventure lies ahead of me because I'm
moving forward in my life I'm not stuck
in the past well you know and needing to
drive a sports car to try to pick up
chicks you worm and so they come
together as a family and then they
defeat the bad guy and as if this
weren't clear enough that the these two
old characters at the end Frank and
Ollie one says he goes he goes oh that's
old school they did it the old school
way the other guy says there's no school
like the old school right that's the
like oh yes he did the traditional thing
and that worked that saved the day
even you know the way they beat the bad
guy is they do things that families do
they argue over a remote they the father
throws a pass like a football pass to
his son right it's so beautiful it's a
really good movie I mention that because
this new movie is so much worse it's so
bad it's like if the second movie is an
apology for the first movie the second
movie begins there will be some spoilers
later not quite yet the second movie
begins exactly where the first movie
left off so it's not like there's a huge
time delay here and then it basically
just undoes the first movie everything
in the first movie it just says now
never mind I'm sorry we shouldn't have
said that
so something you probably have already
heard probably from the trailer is that
this movie is much more focused on the
wife on Elastigirl
so here comes some spoilers she's got
all the action sequences she's gonna you
know she's gonna go she's gonna do the
job she's gonna fight the bad guys and
her her husband is gonna be stuck at
home with the kids which he obviously
screws up because what an idiot husbands
are right I mean wives are just so much
more confident than their husbands like
can he even can even work a microwave ha
ha ha right and look this is the oldest
joke in in cheap humor right this is
every sitcom every TV commercial for the
past 30 years it's been about how the
wife does everything great she's perfect
she's the genius she's brilliant she's
totally competent and the husband that
guy can barely put his shoes on what a
dummy what how does that guy how did he
make it out of like his house is a kid I
mean I use so without getting hit by a
bus or something that that's what they
set up here they the the movie can never
give the wife any character flaws if she
has to do everything perfectly and she
did and and mr. incredibly is just sort
of tangential but another reason again
some more spoilers here why this is
under it undercuts the first movie is it
in the first movie it's mr. incredible
who looks at his old days doing all the
adventures with the bad guys and stuff
and the wife says no you're a family man
now get a job live in the suburbs raise
your family be a good guy she doesn't
want to go off and fight bad guys she
doesn't want to go off on her own and
have independent adventure and then in
the second movie which begins exactly
where the first movie lets off all of a
sudden she said never mind no I want to
go fight bad guys on my own again oh no
that'll be fun oh that was so fun when I
fought that bad guy on my own it's just
this feminist undercutting of the whole
thing and now some people are saying
major spoiler here so close your ears
for 20 seconds if you don't want to hear
it that the the villain in this movie is
a feminist
she's like a sort of it's a embodiment
of feminism right okay villainous things
are villainous so that's true I mean
that that is how that plays out in
movies but it doesn't make up for it it
doesn't make up for what the whole movie
is saying at the end it's just it just
becomes this popcorn movie I'm not
saying that Incredibles 2 is a feminist
screed you know and it's awful and it's
ruining society it's just like men it's
just if I had just seen Incredibles 2
and not seeing the original right
beforehand I would say okay well I
probably won't even talk about it I'd
say well that was whatever compared to
all the other stuff coming out of
Hollywood whatever but because it's it's
an answer to the first I think it's a
real missed opportunity it took them 14
years to turn a wonderful life into an
episode of Everybody Loves Raymond I
mean it is so so frustrating so let me
know what you think I know people have
been tweeting me about this for two days
since I put my review out so let me know
what you think I'm happy to hear more
about it but I have to tell you I'm
completely right so that's the show
today tune in again tomorrow we have
some pretty crazy guests coming up I
don't want to ruin it though and tell
you all about it in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show I'll see you tomorrow
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you